[Music]
hey everyone
so my name's Andy for my company called
Sagami and we produced this this tools
that's used by a lot of fun different
kinds of biologists and various people
doing the applied image processing and
then one of the what I really wanna talk
about today is the way that we got
people using it and the specific people
we really needed to get using it work or
installing it first and then it's going
on their systems works kind of
university systems administrators these
kind of guides so asking whether basic
science products you're really trying to
actually make an impact in the world get
it out to this for kind of people so
what did we have to do well the main
thing was to make it easy to install and
so so the tool that we use to make it
easy to install as Condor constructor so
Condor constructor is a open-source
product produced by continuum that goes
alongside and all of the rest of the
Condor build environment and
yeah as I said before we've got
typically you may be thinking about
producing the software that's about data
scientists implementations but actually
yeah it's this whole group of other
people in universities that have fewer
technical skills and then we've heard
talks about them Jupiter dashboards etc
that a ways of getting your software out
season so and recently we got some
feedback it was the best installer
someone had ever used it and you were so
surprised because it was using Python
and they it was actually easy to install
on his windows laptop it also so the
github URLs here and it was just to
bundle up a one step installer or a
graphical installer for Windows for your
condo projects so the sort of things you
can set up on its hour and start menu
items desktop icons custom scripting
before and after you install a license
agreement and it should work for any
Condor package so sort of packages we
used fell into a few types we have this
Sagami dependencies package which was
just all our dependencies so that we
could avoid duplicating the dependencies
between the constructor files and the
rest of our development pipeline we did
then have our own Fork serves various
pip packages with some customs Condor
packages so I'll show you on the next
slide but we we actually packaged in
things like net framework which we used
to wrap the Windows service around out
out all we had our own kind of compiled
encrypted source code and we had even
was possible to packaging other
programming languages like Java
I all under Conda and so you start off
with a constructor Yama file you've got
a number it's very similar to a normal
combo package you've got your channels
your version for the actual polling
school there you've got a number of sort
of dependencies and then you've got at
how long okay then you've got yeah
images that come up in the graphical
installer you going to the you are the
directory with you construct like yellow
and you're in constructor dot is yeah we
did a few crazy hacks with it we made it
build under Linux asked me about it if
you're interested and then yeah so
thanks to everyone for listening thanks
to character and being a great mentor
for me and yeah anyone's interested
anyone wants to come and work for it get
in touch thank you Andy hello okay so my
topic is going to be data for evil and
that's sort of inspired by our earlier
keynote speech what which was data for
good but I put a question mark because
you'll find out soon enough and I'm a
master student at Kings and I'm going to
work for emphasis at India this summer
so mine take on my personal I guess
involvement is in Python and data less
so in science and magic because it's
quite difficult understand sometimes so
I think this quote is quite endearing
for me because it's one of the
professor's that told me you have no
control over who uses your data and for
what purpose in the future and she was
talking basically about how her research
had been utilized for all in a good way
which I'm going to explain now so the
topic that my background is Libya not
libera so it's going to be on the right
side up that side
so why libya because of cultural
artifacts there two notions
Carthaginians Greeks Romans Arabs
Ottomans do bed or went through Libya
it's quite interesting now it's in civil
war so many of it is being destroyed
sandy but there's a lot of well five
UNESCO Heritage Sites alone and yes
that's being under destruction right now
sandy and it's why I use this case it's
because it's the only case I can think
of where what's being used for good
otherwise I think it's all being used
for bad like target acquisition and
drone strikes and all but not so sad
thing so this is just an example of what
there is Greek I think these are Roman I
think I'm not a classic student so I
would not know for sure so that's the
history that's the current well 2011
Civil War
Gaddafi overthrown NATO no-fly zone
that's sort of the nutshell I suppose
and in the process NATO wanted to find
out who were going to what they were
going to strike and who they were going
to strike and so so the good thing was
these people kill poached the professors
involved in this research where they had
pinpointed locations of Greek Roman
artifacts and heritage so you can search
it here or on the bottom link and
basically these people came over and
said hey or we're going to be creating
no hit list and we're going to give it
to NATO and we're gonna give it to em OD
Ministry of Defence on the British lied
and they said okay sure and then they
gave them the data of course there's
always the bad things that happen so
they are collected by the professors
which was used in the academic context
was used in something that they never
intended which is quite sad but I
suppose that's how data is used
certainly the Heritage Sites that were
not destroyed by NATO
what is joy later by the militia dealers
our dealers were always there and like
people like sizes I guess
so a preferred at least a least I tried
the civil was ongoing sadly and if
there's any left is still in danger
according to UNESCO so so other use
cases for data in in war usually it's
these three things or more simulation
and modeling there was agent-based
modeling earlier it's so dark I see
similar supply chain logistics I worked
on the logistics so aerospace logistics
and a lot of it is to do with predicting
when is the next malfunction Excel etc
and then of course the most typical who
should I kill so the takeaway is um
they're collected a might not be used
the way you intended and you know I
think it applies to everyone yes and so
leave behind good quality data not
because or I can't predict who's going
to use it anyway but at least let's hope
that you'll be use for good
it's sort of an optimism right there and
then data in defense is really
questionable sandy and of course war is
evil so thank you for our sponsors and
thank you PI data thank you so you may
recognize me from yesterday's lightning
talks
I seem to want the attention but I'm not
going to replace Emlyn with a tweet bot
today he's no suffered enough by being
beaten by a dead man in the best tweet
competition and so I one of the hats I
actually wear as I'm a volunteer for
data kind and you all heard wonderfully
about it this morning they didn't use
any of this project so I thought I'd
throw this out there this was some kind
of cool results we did me if you didn't
pay attention yesterday that's me
data kind the great thing is because
you've already had a keynote I don't
have to explain who they are they do
great works you're all brilliant people
who can do great things with data and
you should all volunteer and this is why
the project that we did the dive we did
back in November UK has actually doesn't
quite groundbreaking they have required
all companies to release the ultimate
beneficial ownership of them you cannot
just now
in your annual filing report you are
owned by company B you have to find out
who owns Company B in there has to be a
human person at the end of that chain if
there is an individual who has
significant control so we wanted to take
the early release of the data and see if
we could find interesting things in
there that might map to fraud or tax
avoidance or things that aren't good for
society
so ripping off Marvel this is kind of
the idea and the concept of one of the
teams that I was working with that we've
got companies that are controlled by
people like evil Green Goblin but they
may be connected down to media companies
that you don't think are evil but you
want to actually figure out what's going
on are they registered in the Cayman
Islands versus registered in the US that
sort of thing of course this is all
really difficult because actually it
turns out companies house despite
claiming they have very clean data don't
where you your nationality is a free
text box so people declare themselves as
cornish or British with two T's so I
want to give a special shout-out to
these two guys they try to deduplicate
our data when trying to figure out if
one person was actually the same person
for a lot of this it's beyond the scope
of this lightning talk but go and have a
look at their github I'll put the link
out to this after the lighting talks but
what we actually did was we took like
65,000 companies and an equipment number
of people you can kind of kind of see
the numbers of companies and number of
people the number location and we built
up this massive graph network which is
great is fairly simple basic sets of
relationships but here's the cool thing
we did this in neo4j we did it in the
community edition which is nice and free
and easy to use and it instantly allows
you to visualize the results of your
queries so it in a hackathon style
environment it was really good to get
going so the sorts of things you can
suddenly find are these huge large
corporate structures no one person does
control this this is Reckitt Benckiser
so you can find all the way down to
Lloyd's pharmacies are hidden away in
there all the way up to the master
pharmaceutical company at the other end
this was kind of one of the key things
we're trying to find tax havens so
certainly
you see this company this person is
registered actually in the Cayman
Islands and they sorry a company that
company's registered there it controlled
that company which is controlled by this
person who actually is rated in the UK
and a citizen of Germany are they paying
their taxes appropriately is that the
sort of thing that you can suddenly
easily get out what else did we find
also we found that there is a 20 year
old woman in London who owned seven
hundred and fifty eight companies each
one is got one share worth one pound so
it's actually probably not dodgy it's
something called a company Factory we
were informed we didn't know about this
but you can start finding all of these
really kind of cool interesting networks
and maybe there's something that needs
to be done and ultimately what would the
impact we had well you take data you
take a load of volunteer data scientists
you plug them into a data dive give them
a load of coffee pizza and beer and 20
hours later we had results that actually
the UK governor's agreed to adjust some
of the data and fix some of the problems
Companies House is addressing some of
their free text fields hopefully we
developed a number of leads which were
going into some investigative journalism
pieces which hopefully will appear in
The Guardian and we even got called out
by the government in France at an
anti-corruption summit saying we're an
example of best practice such that
Nigeria and Belgium then contacted data
kind UK saying how do we do that and
with some other stuff details there is I
will however say a number of blog posts
including one of my own and also the
pointy hat calm feel free to go and have
a look if you've got any questions you
can grab me if you can see me if not
you'll see me the PI data
[Applause]
Thanks so this was going to be my only
slide and then I know I felt embarrassed
so I need some more so I had the idea of
just plotting the Wi-Fi data that my
laptop collected over the weekend so so
this is upload speed this is download
speed and the size of the dots is the
ping time so bigger is bad and then I
thought well so note the scale on this
because I didn't keep the scales
constant from plot to plot in part
because it becomes unreadable I had this
idea then that maybe I should show a
couple other Wi-Fi networks so this is
my home network back when I had 500
megabits fiber and it goes up to 100
there you can see and then we got
gigabit fiber and it looks like that I
have somewhat more data because there
was a bug and I was forgetting to note
the name of the of the network so I have
lots of data where I don't know what
network it was this is interesting
because I use speed tests to gather the
data and I'm pretty sure that speed test
just can't find a counterparty that can
measure a gigabit connection the by the
way do you guys know speed tests model
business model they they sell data
they've gamified finding out what your
what your network connection details are
and then they sell the data to Internet
companies to find out so that they can
find out what the network actually looks
like from the consumer side so this is
the set of all Wi-Fi data I've collected
over time where I actually have a
network name now you can set this down
for just a second
so then I felt bad and I just made the
same plots with color maps so so now the
the light things are I think are the
older ones and the dark ones are newer
and I suck at making color maps so the
so it's almost black and white instead
of gray scale but it's the same one
again with my home network and here's
the same one again with my gigabit home
network and here's the same one with
sort of everything I've ever seen
lightning talk you want ask questions um
oh um
well so for example here's B guessed
right so what this tells us is that we
get quite a bit of variety in terms of
what connectivity we get that on the
plus end we're getting about 60 60
megabits per second upload and 70
download and at the bottom end we're
getting something like 10 and it tells
us that it's roughly it's this
relatively good correlation between the
two of them compared to say this right
where the correlation isn't as good so
it's just sort of a I mean practically
it tells us there's a lot of variation
beyond that I'm not sure it provides
anything useful
I don't know wait now I mean yeah you
know we we learn what we can from the
data and then that leads us to ask other
questions one thing one question that it
made me ask and I'd be really curious if
someone can think of a way to do this is
to measure how long it takes to connect
to a Wi-Fi network because for the first
time in my life I was really curious
what the distribution of that time was
so anyway that's that's about Wi-Fi
now one of the things you may have seen
over the last few days the little scoop
a piece of software that I wrote for
creating slideshows and I decided if
it's a stupid piece of software I'll
name it after a stupid person so I
called it m12 I've decided from now on
that every piece of software I write
will be named after somebody I know and
the reason for that is I don't really
want other people to use this code so
the less documentation the less
explanation and the more obscure the
name the less of a chance anyone will
ever use this that's it for those of you
who are there at the pub quiz yesterday
you got to see a little bit of what this
tool can do because in about 15 minutes
of time we took what was a fairly simple
slide for presentation and added some
very sophisticated elements to it if you
were there at the puzzles you saw that
this is our pop quiz and you see there's
some flashy text and you can actually
see we we know how many questions are
left
we're actually counting how much time
there is less so as we go through the
questions the time goes down the
estimated time to completion actually
goes down so you can see are we on track
to end when - they're like 10:30 so we
weren't as you can see and this is all
like just a Tom kloiber was like hey
could we add this could we add this
could we add this and we hacked it
together the code was terrible but I
love tools where you can just kind of
hack something together and it works now
before I actually show you a little bit
on the tool I want to show you one or
two of my favorite questions from the
quiver quiz especially for those who
missed it so I would say this is about
the hardest the public people were
complaining how hard it was this is the
hardest question on the pop quiz
probably it's not that hard but it
wasn't my favorite question that one was
okay
my favorite question was and this
section is called spot the bug my
favorite question was let's see where we
can find it give me a second split up
the gimmicky text actually ended up
being a little bit a little bit helpful
it's right in here so this is my
favorite this is my favorite question
plot the bug those two lines this here
is a tab this is spaces so English it
consisted in this patient error so that
was my grade one oh you can see that
they play link when you're out of time
so we could keep on track the other
really cool section I thought about the
pub quiz was that this question here
which was it was called the names are
changed protect innocence can you guess
this one here can you guess what library
were using and what the Who am I is and
so we have to guess some things about
common libraries we use everyday so for
those of you missed a pop quiz you
really missed out now let me tell you a
little bit at the tool m12 by the way
emmalin one is not this guy over here
he's emmalin three emmalin one was my
first variant of this tool where it
ended up being kind of crappy the idea
was i wanted to be able to write slides
really quickly if I give a one-hour talk
I want to spend one hour writing the
slides so can I just have there's a tool
called cents from a group called
succulence and they basically had a
slideshow tool like this written a
thousand lines of C I hacked on it a bit
it didn't do what I wanted so I decide
to rewrite on Python so I ended up
starting to add like directives and you
can do weird stuff like you can put
Python code and vettern it and it got
Messier and Messier and Messier and
Messier and so on the flight to PI data
Amsterdam I had 6 hours so I decided let
me just rewrite it from scratch because
that's what you do on a flight to a
Python conference I guess surprisingly
when I try to explain this to my friends
and family who are normal people they
have no idea what's going on and they
actually often specifically tell me that
they regret asking me what that is but
for you I guess this is totally normal
so I rewrote this as m12 and it ended up
being much simpler the idea being that
if you think about it a slide is just a
generator that yields the text that's
going to show up on the screen once you
have a generator you can do pretty much
anything inside that generator it's just
it's just a function just a KO routine
so you could for example pull data from
a Google Doc you can do all sorts of
things and that's how basically every
effect is generated on m1 - just a
generator you write yourself and so this
is the actual these are the this is the
questions for the pop quiz we were able
to put them together very quickly
because each question is just the text
it shows up and we were able to put
little tags on here and to do things
like pulse the text and whatnot all of
that was just a Python script the
thought is that I like writing Python
scripts I don't like writing slide shows
so instead of writing slide shows i'll
just write everything as a python script
and so the pub quiz itself is 163 line
python script that includes all the
behavior that it has plus a text file
that just loads slide from it very
simple so this code will probably be put
on it's already on github it'll probably
updated on github when I get back
there's a couple of things I need to do
better I really don't want any
to use it except I keep trying to
convince Thomas Cleaver to use it just
as a point of pride outside of that I
don't know how useful of a tool that
actually is but it confuse them gimmicky
things like solve these slides and yeah
it's it's a way to create slideshows
really really quickly
there is one core message that I take
away from this because whenever I do
corporate training I always tell people
Python is a system itself and has an
enormous amount of functionality when
you're writing million line frameworks
on top you're doing it wrong and that's
exactly the progress that I went through
with m12 the very first version was a
humungous framework with all sorts of
modalities the second version was will
it's just a Python generator and the
third version was what's just a Python a
really simple Python generator and so
the last version of this tool the one
that hopefully none of you will ever use
oh wait no none of you use it anyway so
whatever but the last version of tool
will actually keep this idea Python is a
very complex system as a language has an
enormous amount of moving parts and
mechanisms and you can actually build
very complex tools without writing lots
of code without writing huge frameworks
by just sticking to what is Python to by
figuring out generators a slide will
keep it like that thank you thank you
hi so what I wanted to do today is to
defy the gods of the live demonstration
by proving enduring cause of lightning
talk how easy it is to get the [ __ ]
notebook running on a Linux system have
no idea how difficult it is to get
running on a Windows system because I've
not used Windows for quite a while but
basically what I want to tell you is
I've got nothing up my sleeve so you
will notice at the beginning of this
clip that I'm going to run
I set the path which only new includes
user local bin so I can do it double you
get of the download file the rest is
stuff that you'd expect to see on more
or less any shell so what I did was I
went and I found the URL of the Mac iOS
64 bit bash installer and it's very
simple basically once you've got that
URL you just download the installer
which is a shell script you execute the
Installer
you've then got Conda you can create an
environment because of course you never
do anything in your roots and
parenting in in Python you create a new
virtual environment you install Jupiter
in it and you run the notebook service
so hopefully we'll be able to get all
that done before the end of the
lightning talk so this is what it looks
like as a script basically I set the
path I then do a double you get of the
file I then run that file you
specifically got to use the bash shell
there so that that's very important once
you've done that basically you've
installed pythons so you have to sorry
it's all condor so you have to make sure
that the newly installed system is on
the pass the one thing I have to do is
because I'm running the Installer
interactively I have to make sure that
my user input does actually
no thank you that's all right would be
good that does actually end up putting
the plate in the Condor installation
where I want it I then create a new
virtual environment Condor environment
called demo
I activate that I installed Jupiter into
it and I run the Jupiter notebook so
that is the plan so you'll see that I
have here in another window I've got
this shell script ready to go this is
just to prove that I haven't tweaked the
script it's all it's the exact stuff
they saw on that slide so now because it
is not intended to be a permanent
installation I'm going to do it in temp
and then I'm going to time running that
command so here we are we're downloading
the installer file that's come down in
three seconds now I've got to say yes
okay here's the license values q2
indication I have actually fully read it
and understood it I now make sure that I
use and the reason why I'm using a
script is anyone who's seen we type
those it'll take you a week if I decide
to do do the typing okay so now comes
the awkward anxious waiting bit what's
going on in there well good installing
PI 3.6 now looks good very uh sort of
page is going down as well lovely
creating the default environment do you
wish the Installer to prepend the
install location no I won't bother doing
that
you but it very kindly does tell me what
I should do so while it's fetching the
metadata to Jupiter you can just copy
that it's only in the script so I don't
need to do so let's now proceed and you
can see that it's installing all kinds
of stuff the jupiter needs change oh
there we go it's really good so now I'm
actually installing the Jupiter stuff
all the dependencies widgets extension
in blah blah blah proceeds and that
downloads all these files is actually
probably the longest part of the process
particularly that one QT file seems to
be extremely big the rest of them come
down fairly quickly it's now downloaded
all the dependencies that puts Jupiter
into the Contra environment I've created
and again we have a little tense weight
because nothing actually appears to be
happening but honestly it is there is
stuff going on in the background I think
good wonderful day Chloe right until now
everything was going very well
oh there we go and so now we have a
gypsy page I can actually create a new
plugin free notebook I can import this
and I can print the version to show you
that I have indeed got the very latest
Python three six one from continuum
analytics and if I control C that server
that all happened in two minutes 22
seconds thank you very much
[Applause]
okay so um most people how you are using
bison to do those things
I come from C++ background and
occasionally I'd like Python to be able
to call my C++ functions and ideally I'd
like to do this without me to do any
work at all so this tool has to don't
get up will laugh will help me do that
so because I'm not nervous enough it's
still gonna be live coding so yeah we'll
YouTube the notebook that thing's
working so let C++ over here there's not
a lot of it's not be complicated it's
defining them after that check pass and
in a circle which drives on it it's got
PI in which everyone knows is for um and
will YouTube to network or to spread
that out the disk so it's it's written
out shape that for us and then we can
invoke playing and compile it and see if
it's valid teapot bus and that doesn't
say anything and if we make a mistake
we'll get all blue eyed instead then
playing will tell us that light is on
and ice will go in it is wheel it will
go properly well at some point so okay
so then we'll weed in the code using Lib
clang which is a C API into the compiler
internals
so that gets ready we'll import the
Python module for lip plane and with all
the translation units after the
translation units I will build a will
AST a translation unit ast is the
abstract syntax tree if the compilers
understanding of what it's just seen in
the code and it looks like this and we
could have it with some fighting
together a tree representation of the
code so this if you can't some people
this is even worse understand people's
closet this is still even worse so we
don't want to work with that like yeah
okay I can believe the compiler
understand that so its first thing we'll
do is build some simple Python classes
to turn that ast it's something we can
wait so I have add some coke and will
consume the translation unit using that
CPP model and that gives you nice
methods like functions of classes so we
can see we've swallowed up this ast
we've imported things from standard
library it's got methods called to
string and operator s and all sorts on
it we can have it to the class lines and
we can see it's got chasing circle in
there and then we can have a look at
content of things which were called
shake and then we say that though well
so you can see it's got the names
function names form shape so that's good
looks like we've got some input for
stage 2 it's going to be Cochin so I'm
using ginger 2 templates to do this that
may be a regrettable decision I'm not
sure but people know lots about ginger 2
templates and can tell me what I'm doing
wrong or listen to them at length it
does work um so we'll feed those ginger
2 templates I will Phoebe input we got
from the ast which has been consumed as
advising classes into these ginger two
templates which will happily consume
Python and run my little code generator
scripts I'm telling if I want some sea
based stuff I want a Jason you can see
on the home screen and I want also some
Python because well surprise in
confidence so why not so it'll run and
let's see well it's great it's filled my
disc with some nice things and I can
have a look at one of those and we can
see you've got Jason for shape and it's
got some methods in it that looks very
good and here I guess it'll be hairy
well right see make lists file out and
we'll compile it so we won't see make
lifts file and hold your breath okay so
that's built we'll have a look at the
shared library built so it's built a
shared library which has got functions
for things like shape circle create
shapes and for area which looks good
it's got a whole load of other load of
debugging info which one are we
interested in we'll have a look at the
Python bindings it's produced so it's
generated some Python bindings and then
we can go down to the bottom and we can
fire running those so we'll run Python
to will run the shape class which is
created by some team pi PI Intel's
Python and then okay put a negative
radius into a shape thank you I put a
negative radius into the shape up you go
to the top and see boss boss quite
correctly it says you put negative
radius into a shape that's going to
generate an exception and to an
exception so they're nice and talked to
it so that's what see what happens in
Python ovens so it should probably bring
the whole thing crashing down now this
gets translated into a white an
exception on that gets taught across
here avi boundaries for us okay so I
said at the top I was for so if anyone
still doesn't believe that this is live
we can go in correctly
all of them and at the bottom and we'll
see ladies has changed where this change
areas change so yes so called various
items and bounce now got a slightly more
accurate valuation of the area so yes
there's an open source library don't get
hub it's Ana Provari early stages of
development and anyone interested please
grab my office Thanks table I talk about
Jupiter dashboards on Friday so I
decided to do this lighting talk it was
pretty much inspired by the brilliant PI
spotter spark Cambridge talked earlier
today so I wanted to share it to share a
few things first of all AWS lamda who
uses any W on there or AWS internal AWS
abbs lambda now offers Python 3.6
because previously it was only a hockey
version of 3.4 alright so that's things
I know but they offer three point six
and that's a great also PI part is super
easy it's easy to super easy to setup
even on Windows I will show both in a
second so first I want to go through the
slide so to make sure that nothing goes
wrong during the live demo and yeah
speak to me if you're interested in
either of these aspects like running a
degree as lambda 3.6 3.4 notebooks and
zapping as well right so that's sport
okay so here's how it'll be is lambda I
have a function that is you know like in
this in AWS lab where you have a
callback so if you want to execute
something you have to call it directly
so using let's say sub-process
and that's what we're going to do a test
okay we just sort of execution and here
can you see in the box here it says it's
three point six point one yes obviously
is running on Linux and I was like so
what do you guys give us as a people
six because 3.4 version was really
cut-down version of Python now they give
us pretty much the standard library that
you see the I don't think I don't see
modules like tab Nene but that looks
like pretty much all the standard
libraries here so that's good next topic
is white part on Windows look it's
genius
right so so here I just earlier today
earlier today like after I guess after
5:00 already I set up for a spark on my
machine I ran some tasks so that was the
computation of pine well like raspberry
PI's and just by so this is just a
number of pine
here is the here's the notebook that
actually uses PI spark so what we have
is we have a master node and we have
like workers but it's only one worker at
the moment if you if you wanted to
connect you will be able to share your
CPU time so just to show you that it
should run
so basically the way it works this is
scale this is to scalability you can
keep attaching workers to your master
node and you get you know parallel
execution in Python okay just to prove
that we are running the first byte look
it's running it's running anyone you
know in ten seconds so it's all
finishing about yes it's say this now
[Music]
all right so these are the main kind of
bits of information that I wanted to
share with you and I hope you can make
use of it it will be lambda packs and
3.6 PI spark is awesome can be set up on
windows easy get in touch with me if you
want to know how and I should probably
also probably write it up well we have
some times definitely notebooks I
mentioned I kind of used you see I kind
of used them in my previous slides and
look they're awesome like so you so the
things that you can do with zeppelin
notebooks is these are kind of the
languages i suppose or flavors that i
available spark markdown yes angular
nice shell sequel elasticsearch nice and
some things that I haven't used and the
plots that are brilliant so once you
visualize the data I don't have an
example of the sequel come on here yes
we do
so that's just look cool all right well
thank you guys and thank you I want to
thank the organizers of this conference
it's been brilliant and see you guys
around
[Applause]
[Music]